listen up I found the perfect person to play with no one works harder canonical this is draymond Green Thank You Isaiah Tom we are not a championship thing right now but I promise we will be yo dream on you don't have to shout we are right here shouting both shout this is my normal heart try whispering what like this can you even hear me I got an idea let's have a dunk contest ah let's I will see who can touched in that contest let's do that now you see my clothes that was either somebody press play on my new R&B album it's time to push Oh No close yo I got it I got net you didn't know that's what you my love loving about basketball